thank you Yer well it is um a a great
honor to be talking here in honor of um
on this occasion um uh and uh and as
yaer said mostow's work especially uh in
my field mow rigidity is an absolute
Bedrock uh principle and one of the
amazing things about this
this uh result is that it's not just the
statement of the result which is
important although the statement is of
of enormous consequence but it's every
idea in the proof is important and so it
it's my great pleasure to start this
lecture by talking about just one
special instance but one of the most
important instances of Mel's rigidity
theorem so this talk will be in two
parts I'm going to start talking about
real hyperbolic three
manifolds and uh then there'll be a
second part about uh complex hyperbolic
manifolds um which will uh raise some
different issues and uh I'll describe
some current research topics there I'll
also try to draw attention to some open
problems that remain in this very active
field okay so this um development
subsequent to Mel's work and to a
certain extent prior that I'm going to
discuss the main player are alfor
Sullivan gromov and thirst so let me
start with Mel's proof of mow rigidity
um so here's a here's the statement of
the special case I'm interested in and I
find this I still find this case amazing
every time I think of it if you have two
compact hyperbolic three manifolds that
is closed three manifolds with metrics
of constant negative curvature if a
purely combinatorial invariant their
fundamental group if their fundamental
groups are is isomorphic as groups then
the manifolds are isometric as manifolds
so for example the volume of the
manifold becomes a topological
invariant uh so here's the proof step
one so these spaces are um are K Pi 1 so
if you have an isomorphism between their
fundamental groups you can realize it by
a homotopy equivalence between the
manifolds so let F be such a map and
then lift to the universal cover so the
Universal cover is the three ball
endowed with the hyperbolic metric in
both cases now the three ball has
hyperbolic geometry so here's a typical
geodesic and the first beautiful idea in
the proof is that the image of this
pristine geometric object under this
sloppy homotopy equivalent becomes a a
quasi geodesic which is in fact close to
being a hyperbolic geodesic it tracks a
unique hyperbolic geodesic so even
though this map
respected in no ways the ranian metrics
on domain and range its lift to the
universal cover is trying its best to
preserve hyperbolic geometry at least up
to a bounded
Factor the Second Step which I think is
is one of the most profound is the
following the fundamental group of M is
acting freely permuting fundamental
domains in this ball but the action
extends to the sphere at Infinity the
natural boundary of hyperb space and
there the action is very complex it
doesn't have any fundamental domains in
fact it's erotic it's erotic on the set
of pairs and um and one can extend this
lifted map from the ball to the boundary
of the ball and the boundary of the ball
it gives a conjugacy between these two
very complex and chaotic dynamical
systems so that's the first point is
that the action of the group on the
sphere on this side is conjugate
topologically to the action on this side
by the boundary values of
f now even better the fact that these
geodesics map to crinkly geodesics means
that the shadow of a ball on the in the
first hyperbolic ball hyperbolic space
the shadow on the sphere at Infinity of
a ball which is round maps to something
that's an approximately round Shadow and
that's that means that the boundary
values of this map or what are called
quasiconformal Maps so let me just
remind you that if you have an isometry
of hyperbolic 3 space it induces a
conformal map of the boundary that is a
mobious transformation if the boundary
values were conformal then the boundary
values of f would be extend to an
isometry that would conjugate one group
to the other and that would end the
proof it would prove that the two
manifolds are isometric and what you get
sort of for free is that the boundary
values are quasiconformal they're
there's they're off by a boundary amount
of distortion that brings us to step two
how can we Analyze This quasi conformal
map and the Beautiful fact is as I just
mentioned if F were conformal we would
be done otherwise there's something kind
of strange happening you have a
invariant complex structure on the
target sphere and you have an invariant
complex structure on the domain sphere
so you can take the target complex
structure and pull it back and the round
circles in the Target if the map is not
formal pull back to ellipses in the
domain of the map if these were round
the map would be conformal but otherwise
it has to really be distorting the
complex structure and then you can
record this Distortion by just drawing
the major axis of the ellipse and
because f is a conjugacy that uh that F
that family of lines one line in each
tangent space of the sphere is invariant
under the action of the group so to
complete the proof we now just have to
show that that's impossible that is
there's no way to coherently choose a
line in each tangent space of the two
sphere so it's invariant under the
action of this of this big group okay
and at that point the map F passes out
of the picture and this is this
beautiful Insight that we can use erotic
theory on the sphere to infinity and I
should mention that this line field is
only measurable and it's a beautiful
fact that we start a beautiful you know
mathematical onot that we begin with a
purely topological discussion and we're
driven to actually
use not entirely UNS subtle results in
measure Theory to complete the proof so
so here's the completion of the
proof so suppose we had an invariant
family of lines on the two sphere I've
drawn a tiny patch of it here well
according to the leag density theorem if
you have a measurable family of lines
then at most points at a very small
scale most most of the lines are
pointing in the same direction but now
we have this huge group of hyperbolic
isometries that's leaving this line
field invariant so we can take a region
where the lines are nearly parallel and
blow it up by a sequence of group
elements that doesn't change the line
field but it takes the region where it
was nearly parallel and it transforms it
to a larger region and so what we're
able to conclude by applying the
Dynamics is that in fact the line field
looks like parallel lines in a standard
ukan chart so it appears that we have a
family of parallel lines on on on the
complex plane say that's invariant of
the action of this group but such a
family of lines when viewed on the
sphere looks like circles all tangent to
the point at Infinity so if you have a a
group action that leaves this family of
lines invariant all the elements of the
group have to fix this one special point
and obviously that's impossible for a
co-compact
group okay so there's many
uh uh ideas in this proof that have been
used over and over again throughout uh
geometry and
Dynamics um so just to give you a hint
of the facundity of this argument let me
just mention one or two further
developments so a lot of work has been
done by investigating what happens when
the group rather than being co-compact
is simply and finitely generated another
way to say this geometrically is we
consider a general hyperbolic manifold
or even orbifold uh it should be
complete but no restrictions on its
volume and um the such an object uh the
quotient three manifold might look
something like this it might have a cusp
it might have some infinite volume
flaring ends that are cut off by
surfaces it might have some weird ends
that uh hopefully look like the product
of a surface with an interval that's
what the quotient manifold looks like
when we go to the action on the sphere
what happens is the action is no longer
chaotic on necessarily on the whole
sphere there may be some regions where
the action has fundamental domain those
are these circles here and then there's
this chaotic Locus left over this is
called the limit set of the group so we
have a much uh richer um class of
dynamical pictures that arise when we go
to infinite volume
and nevertheless the analog of mow
rigidity goes through in this setting so
the first result I'd like to mention is
Sullivan showed that there's a relative
version of moer rigidity namely if you
simply have a finitely generated discret
group then there's no invariant line
field on its limit set and that has
tremendous consequences for the theory
of hyperbolic 3 manifolds it basically
means the different possible shapes of a
given hyperbolic manifold are
parameterized by the remon surfaces at
Infinity so the tyer theory of the
boundary controls the tyer theory of the
three manifold in this way one sometimes
says the theory of three manifolds is
superficial it's all going on on on the
boundary and if there's no boundary then
it's
rigid a second big development along the
same lines uh there's U an important
conjecture formulated by thiren the
ending lamination conject also the
tameness conjecture and and finally with
work of many people Brock Canary Minsky
AOL and calor
gabai we now have a complete
understanding of what all possible
hyperbolic three manifolds with finitely
generated groups look like that is
there's a complete set of invariants
which classifies them there's a
topological and combinatorial invariant
which is roughly the shape of the three
manifold and then there's these remon
surfaces Infinity they range in finite
dimensional Tyler spaces which are well
understood so we now understand all
finitely generated groups that are
discreet and act on hyperbolic fre space
and a particular consequence of this uh
which is a longstanding problem goes
back to the 1960s is the so-called alfor
measure zero conjecture which says the
only way the limit set can have positive
area is if it's the whole
sphere um but this is only the tip of
the iceberg these are results in the
area of three hyperbolic three manifolds
per se so there's a tremendous number of
other mathematical developments that
issue from uh Mel's work and Mel's proof
so for example this simple idea that a g
that a geodesic goes to a quasi geodesic
was abstracted by gromov uh leading to
the definition of hyperbolic groups
hyperbolic groups are groups that have
the combinatorial properties of groups
acting on hyperbolic space and in
particular they have quasi geodesics
that are
stable gromov also contributed a
beautiful idea for doing the proof of
Mel rigidity without using erotic Theory
and this idea leverages the fact that
there is a unique uh tetrahedron ideal
tetrahedron of maximum volume in
hyperbolic 3 space and it sort of
explains why M rigidity fails in
dimension two because all ideal
triangles are isometric but not all the
tetrahedra are there's a cross ratio of
four points on the sphere um so that's
only the beginning of yet another
offshoot of this
development one more that um my thesis
adviser Dennis Sullivan pursued to great
um with great success is the integration
of Mel's argument into complex Dynamics
and especially into the theory of
renormalization so this picture which I
won't explain in detail represents a
very simple but bifurcation pattern in a
family of one-dimensional dynamical
systems so we're doing some iteration on
the real line there's an attractor as we
increase the parameter it bifurcates
into a cycle of order two then four then
eight and then there's this limiting
caner set here and there's all sorts of
beautiful self- similarities in this
picture for example this little bit up
here when blown up looks like a rescaled
version of the entire picture uh that's
qualitative but even better the rate at
which these period doublings occur
this apparent self-similarity around
this special caner set point is a
universal number it's the same in all of
these windows and it's the same in all
one-dimensional families and this is now
explained uh by first passing to the
complex plane and now here we have an a
complex dynamical system with a limit
set I my pointer
is uh with a limit set which is the
black part and as and now we play M the
mow argument that as we start zooming in
on this black set and it becomes more
and
more uh ubiquitous and the point is this
is the area where there's the Dynamics
is destroying any invariant line field
and so we don't quite obtain rigidity
but we obtain asymptotic rigidity and
that's exactly where the existence and
uniqueness of fix points of
renormalization comes
from uh there's other versions such as
the golden mean zagal disc which uh
whose boundary is shown here when you
blow this up it's self similar with some
Universal Factor around the center of
our our picture here um those are all
instances of methods in what broader
field now called conformal Dynamics
which turn on the same motifs that
appear in Mel's
proof okay so let me mention an open
problem uh one of my favorite open
problems in complex Dynamics it the
problem is to really generalize mow
theorem or Sullivan's theorem from
groups acting on the sphere to rational
Maps acting on the sphere so here's the
problem suppose you have a a rational
map on the remon sphere that is ratio of
two
pols uh of let's say of degree one or
two or more it has something called the
Julia set which up to measure zero is
just the closure of the periodic points
that's the analog of the limit set and
the question is the problem is to show
there is no invariant line field on the
Julia set of F and this is open even in
the case when the Julia said it's the
whole two sphere which is roughly like
the co- compact case uh for clan
groups one reason this might be slightly
harder than well there's several reasons
why this seems to be slightly harder
than the original proof for clian groups
that is for hyperbolic fre manifolds one
is that of course a rational map on the
the sphere has critical points so it's
much more nonlinear than uh the elements
of a clan group um the other one is that
this conjecture is
false so um it turns out that the
addition law for the vros P function
gives rise to a very special rational
map on the sphere and that if it's this
rational map is associated to the vros P
function for an elliptic curve and if
you draw the family of parallel lines
for that elliptic curve upstairs in the
complex plane and let them descend to
the remon sphere so think of the
elliptic curve as a two-fold branch
cover of the sphere with the p function
as the map that gives an invariant line
field for the addition law and so any
proof of this theorem is going to have
to single out these uh these addition
law examples as special cases and for
example thiren proved a very special but
interesting version of this theorem
where the critical points of f are pre
perodic and his proof exactly does pick
out these special
cases well as long as I'm mentioning
thirst uh I I can't say Mel rigidity
without mentioning thirst at least in
the case of Dimension 3 because uh what
thirst showed is that most three
manifolds are hyperbolic that is most
three manifolds do carry a metric of
constant NE negative
curvature so you have existence and then
we have uniqueness by mow that's a very
rigid situation and it means for example
that volume is a very good topological
invariant if you want to tell two three
manifolds apart one way to do it is to
compute the uh hyperbolic structure on
them compute the volume if the volumes
do not agree then the manifolds are not
isomorphic now notice that we're in an
odd Dimension so the volume is not given
by gpet formula after all the O the
oiler characteristic will be zero uh the
volume is probably some transcendental
number it's can be written down often in
terms of the luski function but in
Practical terms it turns out to be an
excellent invariant and for example
there there was a long history of which
I'm giving you a glimpse of the
classification of knots there's it's now
possible uh to classify all knots up to
16 Crossings of which there's more than
a million simply using volume and Mild
modifications thereof as a a way for um
as a way to tell them apart so there's
been a tremendous impact uh on the
theory of three manifolds by the fact
that rigidity holds for these canonical
metrics in in some sense the combination
of mosow and thirston is a fitting
sequel to The uniformization theorem
proved at the turn of the last century
it's that was a two-dimensional theorem
for remon surfaces and now we have a
topological threedimensional theorem
that's uh that's very similar now of
course I should mention that the
although th did the case of knots the
completely General version of this
theorem is uh was is due to
Peron okay so that's a glimpse of the
central role of midity in the theory of
three
manifolds let me turn to uh my second
topic um which will pick up on this
theme that volume is
useful so I would like to talk about the
use of complex hyperbolic
volume no longer real hyperbolic volume
for uh as a tool in the study of moduli
spaces um and this is this discussion
I'm going to present uh it was prompted
by a recent pre-print of uh cap and Muer
uh but it goes back to some work of
thirston in 1998 some work of delen and
mow in prior to that and finally a
beautiful and not very well-remembered
paper by Alan derer and VY in uh
1943 um okay so let's let me let me try
to set the stage for this discussion so
I'd like to apply rigidity volume
computations um Etc in the setting of
moduli spaces now what moduli spaces am
I going to consider I I'd like to
consider the the one of the simplest
which is the moduli space of n distinct
points on the sphere and these points
are labeled they they're numbered B1 up
to BN so this is just a manifold it's
it's uh it's the it's a list of end
points modulo the action diagonal action
of the automorphism group of the remon
sphere um so this manifold is usually
called m0n it's remon surfaces of genus
zero of which there's only one with n uh
Mark points on it um now before we
discuss volume let's discuss Oiler
characteristic and you might be
anticipating that since we're in even
Dimensions now since we're talking about
complex manifold volume is not going to
be an interesting invariant because
volume should be proportional to Oiler
characteristic uh in in this setting so
let me first compute the oil
characteristic of this moduli space
because it's not very hard so there's
forgetful map if you have n marked
points then you can just throw away the
last one then you have n minus one
marked points and that presents moduli
space as a uh as a fi F fiber bundle uh
over a moduli space of smaller Dimension
and the fiber is just a surface of genus
zero with n minus one uh U points
removed so punctured at n minus one
points if you've chosen n minus one
points you're not allowed to pick those
for your nth point so you throw away
those points and then you pick a point
in their complement and uh well I know
how to compute the O characteristic of
the N minus one sign punctured sphere
and so by induction you compute that the
orer characteristic of moduli space is a
factorial it's up to sign it's simply n
minus 3 factorial where n is the number
of
points okay so now let's shall we
compute the volume of moduli space uh
using Gus pet well yes and no so first
let me tell you the no part
modulized spaces are not hyperbolic so
much as I might like to compute the
complex hyperbolic volume of this
manifold it does not have a complex
hyperbolic structure that's compatible
with the complex structure that it's
already uh that's already god-given so
so the moduli space of of uh of five or
more points is never isomorphic to a
quotient of complex hyperbolic space
unfortunately so it's
not in in this setting thon's theorem is
false there's plenty of of manifolds
that have the topological features of
complex hyperbolic manifolds but don't
carry complex hyperbolic metrics that's
very rare in fact for complex manifolds
and one of the reasons we know this is
that there's a beautiful theorem of
reiden uh you see if modulized space
were complex hyperbolic then its
Universal cover would be this beautiful
symmetric space they would be just just
a ball in CN it would have a huge
automorphism group even as a complex
manifold but reyen showed that in fact
the universal cover of moduli space has
a discrete group of automorphisms in
fact the automorphisms just come from
the mapping class group of the end times
punctured sphere that is roughly uh they
come from the braid group and uh
consequently there's no homogeneity to
the universal cover in fact the
universal cover is as inhomogeneous as
possible um so my orig origal question
is foundering but just for a
moment okay so
now uh let me continue and discuss a way
of thinking about the modulized Bas of
end points on the sphere so suppose
you're just given end points on the
sphere how can what kind of geometry
might underly this
configuration so so here's a beautiful
idea let's add more data to the picture
so we're going to fix some weights
on our end points the weights will be
between zero and one and the sum of the
weights will be
two and
then what I want to point out is the
following if you have these weights plus
actual locations for end points on the
sphere well then you have a naturally
determined meromorphic one form on the
sphere namely you put a pole of weight
mui at the I point and then you just
take the product
so there's a meromorphic one form with
poles along these points bi notice that
the the divisor of this form which would
be the uh there should be a minus sign
here the sum of these U mui times the B
it has degree to as as should uh any uh
anti-canonical divisor on uh on on the
sphere
um and and uh and so that's a lot of
additional data the only problem
yeah no because there are no integers
between zero and one
so yeah so so one of the problems but
it's not a big problem and it wasn't a
problem in the 19th century by the way
you would just write this down and say
there's a meromorphic function and now
let's integrate it and do whatever we
want with it but of course this is a
multivalued function as I presented it
however its absolute value is perfectly
well defined and it's when you put an
absolute value signs in it then becomes
a metric because the absolute value of
DX is a conformal metric it's a way to
measure distances on the sphere that's
compatible with the angles so forget
this is think of this as 19th century
and this is 20th century so in the 20th
century You observe that this data
determines a metric on the sphere and
because of the fact that this Omega is
holomorphic away from these poles the
metric it determines is flat so it's you
have a flat metric on the sphere with
some sort of singularities at these end
points and in fact this metric turns out
to be isometric to a convex polyhedrin
in R3 and The Cone angles at these bis
are simply are related in a simple way
to the values of these mui so for
example if you take 12 points on the
sphere then you can set all of the mui
equal to 16 and if you take the points
in a very symmetric configuration the
corresponding remon surface plus metric
is isometric to the regular do
deedin okay so this is we haven't
changed our moduli space we've just
changed how to think about it so we can
think of this moduli space with more
data these weights as parameterizing
these different possible shapes of
polyhedra so you should imagine this doc
hedrin which happens to be very static
as having uh some deorations you can
start sliding the vertices around
continue to take their convex Hall in R3
and you'll get a whole family of convex
shapes and if you do it just right you
can keep the cone angles the same and uh
that's what this moduli space is now
parameterizing it's a moduli space of
polyedra and oddly
enough if when you add this perspective
to moduli space it becomes a complex
hyperbolic manifold after
all uh so um
so uh so here's the statement so first
as I just said we can think of this
moduli space with these M's now as a
space of metrics with given cone angles
and uh and the theorem is that moduli
space is now naturally a hyperbolic
manifold and uh in in fact the periods
of this form which are multivalued
functions at least locally defined maps
from this moduli space into uh the
corresponding complex hyperbolic space
okay so let me give you some background
on this result so this kind of result uh
in slightly different language was known
to Schwarz and peard and it was
developed uh very completely by uh delen
and mow who used it to construct some
amazing examples of lates in Su 21 and
Su 31 which we'll come to and then to my
mind this development reached its um
reached it it's Apex with the 1986 math
Olympiad so in the 1986 math Olympiad
there was a problem having to do with a
pentagon and a little game people played
and they had weights on the Pentagon
You' lend money to your neighbors and
one semester at Princeton thirston was
teaching his graduate course and uh
there was no syllabus for the course uh
and a week before the course was to
start he was having lunch with people
and somebody said why don't you talk
about problems like this math Olympian
problem and so he started talking about
this math Olympia problem and by the end
of the course he had
rediscovered the constructions of delen
and mow from an entirely uh geometric
perspective and uh and and taken them
somewhat farther so let me tell you what
what thst's result is um I'll I'll tell
it to you in the case of these this
specific set of Weights so
um uh let me just see if
I'm oh oh sorry so so what I want to uh
uh do here is
explain sorry what I want to do here let
me explain how uh this modulized space
becomes complex hyperbolic so so let me
do it with this specific set of weights
and then we'll come to thst's exact
statement so where does a how can you
put a complex hyperbolic structure on
the space of of polyhedra with these
weights so a particular case is a is
something that's almost a pentagon so
you make the angles proportional to 777
and 8 that gives you a uh a convex body
a convex polygon if you double that
polygon you get a flat metric on the
sphere with the desired cone
angles um and what we want to do is map
the space of such configurations of Five
Points interpreted as polygons into
complex hyperbolic two space let me just
explain how this can be done so so
here's a nice idea a if you have five
points on a sphere you can associate to
that those Five Points a remont surface
of genus 25
canonically how well I'm using the
there's many possible constructions I'm
using the fact that the denominator here
is 18 to make the sum come out to be two
so um what you do is you take the
18-fold cover of the sphere branched
over those points so I put one of the
points at infinity and then I I have a
remon surface that's described by this
very simple apine equation
generalization of a hyperelliptic curve
it's an 18-fold cover of the sphere
branched over branched over five points
now of course this remont surface has a
lot of symmetry in particular the group
Zod 18 act on this surface and it acts
on its homology the action of Zod 18 on
its homology is a purely topological
thing it doesn't depend on where the
points are if we just think of the
complex uh homology it's sort of fixed
once and for all the model for that
doesn't depend on where the points are
located however there is something that
does depend on where the points are
located namely the coomy class
represented by our form so now I'm
answering Pav's question if we take our
form Omega our form Omega can now be
written as DX over Y 7th see y to the Y
is a multivalued function on the remon
sphere on X it becomes single valued and
this is this is now our holomorphic form
Rec
via remon's trick to become a single
valued holomorphic one form on a remon
Surface spread over the sphere and uh
it's so so whenever we have a
configuration of points we have a
canonical line in the complex homology
of the sphere but it's not but remember
there's this zmod 18 action it's not
just in an arbitrary piece of this
homology you can decompose this homology
according to the igen spaces of the Cod
18 and this lies in the igen space base
Associated to one of the 18th roots of
unity namely Theus 7 time the Primitive
18th roots of unity because we have a y
the seven in the denominator
here okay so now here's an interesting
problem in its own right when you have
zont 18 acting on the homology of this
remont surface the remont surface has an
canonical inner product on its homology
coming from intersections of Curves
purely topological that turns the
complex chology
into a herian space of signature GG
where G is the is the genus of the curve
and this aan space is some piece of that
and it has its own herian metric on it
so you can ask what's the signature of
the intersection form restricted to this
uh this piece of the homology and the
answer is given by um uh there's a nice
uh sort of rule of thumb to give the
answer which is you say well there's
four points in the plane so you draw
Four Points equally spaced around the
circle put them at the fourth roots of
unity and then you say I have a 718 here
so you draw 78 on the circle and then
you draw the line from 0 through 718 and
the signature is the number of points
above the line comma the number of
points below the line so the signature
turns out to be one two so in other
words this is isomorphic to a
three-dimensional complex space with a
natural uh herian form on it signature
one two that should already be starting
to make you think of su12 and so now
here's the map you simply send bi the
configuration of points to the
corresponding positive line in C12 the
space of positive lines in C12 is a
model for complex hyperbolic two space
and so that gives a local map from the
configuration of Five Points on the
sphere to complex hyperbolic space it
turns out to be a local homeomorphism
pull back the metric that endows the
moduli space of Five Points on the
sphere with a complex hyperbolic
metric okay
now uh and by the way one of the reasons
I like this example is because all these
weights seven are the same you actually
get a corresponding representation of
the braid group on four strands into u12
and this turns out to be a uh spe
special case of the baral
representations of the braid group okay
so now we can ask what is the volume of
moduli space in this
metric and uh um and here's the
answer so the complex hyperbolic volume
of moduli space in the metric I just
defined is well and then there's some
formula so in this formula there's a
constant which is sort of the standard
constant in Gus Benet and then there's
uh a sum over all partitions of the
integers from one up to n and and then
for each partition there's a a product
over the blocks in the partition and you
have to sum the weights uh over the
elements of this block if the sum comes
out to be more than one you set this
equal to zero Etc okay so there's a
formula for the volume and uh so what
this is just explaining what the formula
is and I should say that this formula
was derived in in special cases by other
different and and also very interesting
methods by by Parker and
saer um okay so now so what I'd like to
do is explain where this formula comes
from uh why it's useful and uh resolve
the Paradox of the fact that I'm
Computing the hyperbolic volume of
something that doesn't have a hyperbolic
metric okay so let me here's here by the
way are uh this is an application of
this formula so so there's there's uh
there were 94 orbifolds that were
discovered by um by delene and mow that
are obtained by choosing particular
values of these mui for those mui the
holom of this complex structure gives a
lattice of this complex hyperbolic
structure gives a lattice in in U in in
unn uh for n equals one and two well
actually for many sorry not just for one
and two and um there's a number which
you have to compute which morally plays
the role of the oiler characteristic and
so the volumes of all of these beautiful
orbifolds are uh tabulated in this table
well that's one of the applications of
the formula so now we come to sort of
the main point that thirst and
contributed so so let me tell you about
cone
manifolds so suppose you're given a
bunch of triangles in the plane and you
glue them together along their edges
whenever the edges have happen to have
equal length glue them together in pairs
then you get something that looks like a
surface but the total angle around the
vertices might not be 2 pi so it's it
has some curvature potentially uh at the
at at the along the zero skeleton after
you glued it up so in the same way you
could take some spherical polyhedrin of
polyhedrin of Dimension three glue them
together along their two-dimensional
faces if some of the two-dimensional
faces happen to be isometric glue them
together in pairs when you assemble this
object you might get something that
looks somewhat like a manifold it has a
metric of constant curvature plus one on
an open Den set but now along the one
skeleton and the zeros skeleton there
will be various there will be various
kinds of curvature um so these more
General objects are examples of cone
manifolds um
and uh there's a version of this idea of
a cone manifold for in the complex
hyperbolic case now I should caution you
that I'm deliberately misleading you
about the Simplicity of this idea and
how I'm the way I'm misleading you is
this in complex hyperbolic two space
there are no hypersurfaces that are
totally geodesic so there's no polyhedra
with these top dimensional faces along
which you can glue so so a hyperbolic
cone manifold whatever it is it can't be
described quite by saying you glue
polyhedra together along geodesic faces
because there are no such
faces in the ranian case things are even
worse nevertheless there's a good and
beautiful definition of a um of a ranian
cone manifold and what thiren showed is
that well when you take the metric I
just described on the moduli space of
end points on the sphere the metric
which depends on the choice of weights
on the points first it's almost never a
complete metric that resolves the
contradiction to be a complex hyperbolic
manifold it would have to be complete
it's almost never complete but its
metric completion is a cone manifold and
this result holds no matter what the
weights are it holds for example even
for real values of the
weights um and now uh we can turn to the
problem of computing the volume and all
we need now to compute the volume is the
following we need a formula a gpet
formula for the volume of a cone
manifold because this object is now
complete and it's it's even typically
Compact and so you would expect that the
complex hyperbolic volume of this
closure is in fact proportional to its
Oiler
characteristic and uh and indeed uh that
is the case in the on the other hand the
original modui spaces it has full
measure so you're just Computing the
volume of m0n when you do that so the
oiler characteristic of the completion
can be used to compute the volume of the
interior and here's the resulting
formula uh so this is a version of the
gbet formula for cone manifolds and what
it says is well you take the usual gbet
integrand you integrate it over the top
dimensional part of the cone manifold
and it's given by an Oiler
characteristic now what is the oil
characteristic well it turns out that
any cone manifold is naturally
stratified and each of the strata is in
fact totally geodesic for the stratified
ranian metric on the manifold and and so
there's a sum over the strata of the
manifold and then you just take the
ordinary Oiler characteristics of the
strata now if this were an actual
manifold the or characteristic would
just be the sum of the or
characteristics of its strata but since
it's a cone manifold
there's a sort of a defect that is that
along each of these strata you can take
the volume of a sphere and you can
compare it to the volume of the sphere
in the manifold and they grow that one
will be proportional to the other by a
constant that constant is a measure of
the cone angle along that stratum and
that's this constant
Theta appearing here okay so there's so
there's a formula for the for there's a
version of the Gman formula for cone
manifolds and it's simply what you would
guess it would
be um so maybe I'll I'll say just a a
word about the history of this so so
capies and Moher sent me a paper in
2012 uh that introduced a very
interesting invariance that I'm going to
allude to and um I said I thought well
there should be a simpler invariant
where you just use the gaus Benet
formula and so I wrote down this formula
and I computed it in the uh delene and
mow examples and uh and then it took a
half year to prove that this formula was
correct so I I went to the library and I
I looked up galb theorem for cone
manifolds and it it didn't exist in
literature uh so let me explain how this
formula can be proved and how in fact
the key ideas in the proof are already
in the literature but they're in a sort
of classical literature that's been
largely superseded in in modern thought
so um but first let me use it to explain
the volume formula I gave earlier so the
volume we wanted to calculate is now
expressed as a sum of Oiler
characteristics and and uh cone
angles here was the formula that I wrote
down before now you can recognize the
pieces this term here is the oiler
characteristic of a
stratum and you'll notice that this
looks like the oiler characteristic of a
modulized space with P
points this term here is the cone angle
transverse to that stratum
and what's happening is that when you
compactify modui space all that's going
to happen is that certain collisions
between points will be allowed for
example the point with weight 71 18 and
718 can Collide to produce a point with
weight 1418 and so the cone manifolds
the the polyhedra with four points on
them with a new set of Weights arise in
the compactification of the cone
manifold for these original weights and
so these Strat are just lower
dimensional moduli spaces
and then some function of the weights
determines what their how they should be
counted what their transverse angle is
um so I'm just saying this Collision
produces a stratum isomorphic to m04
which is one of these terms
here um and there is no Collision
possible by the way if the sum of the
weights uh is is U bigger than one so
for example three of these sevens cannot
Collide because that would give 21 which
is bigger than
18 okay so let me just say a few words
about a proof of the Gan theorum in this
setting so it the proof I know relies on
this beautiful result of alen derer and
Bay in which they computed the oiler
characteristic of an object that's
almost never studied these days called a
compact Ronan
polyhedrin so it's like a polyhedrin but
everything is
curved and uh and the formula in in
involves the usual gusp integrant here
and then some other terms here which are
integrated over over the boundary facets
and then there's the the the outer
angles uh along these facets play a
crucial role and uh so let me just give
you a glimpse of what the terms are like
in this formula this is the traditional
gpet term which involves just the um the
remon curvature tensor along the
interior of the manifold and uh that's
sort of the intrinsic curvature
and then in the second part there's
something that depends on the choice of
a point on the boundary plus a vector in
the in the Dual normal cone to that to
that point and that is a combination of
uh of um of of the ranian curvature and
the the second meal fundamental form
along uh along that that piece of the
boundary um so anyway there's this
beautiful formula D alen derer Andy why
did Allen derer and VY prove this
formula so what happened is that Allen
derper had
proved the expected gbet theorem for
compact ranian manifolds that can be
embedded in ukian space at this time
nobody knew whether or not every
manifold could be embedded in ukian
space and they observed that once you
have that you can just chop your
manifold up into into pieces small
pieces are known to embed in ukian space
and so if you have a suitable formula
for polyhedra then you can sum up all
the pieces and get standard gpan so so
without having Nas's theorem available
aland derer and V actually gave the
first proof of the gpan theorem for
closed manifolds but they did it by
chopping into pieces and so along the
way they proved this beautiful theorem
for a
polyhedra a year or two later churn gave
his beautiful intrinsic proof which has
nothing to do with embeddings into ukian
space and doesn't involve any chopping
and this result was largely forgotten as
far as I can tell looking in math
reviews at the number of times it was
cited but it's exactly what you need to
prove gban for a cone manifold because
what you want to do is cut your cone
manifold into pieces into polyhedra
where the facets of the polyhedra run
along these different strata and um let
me just mention that this formula of
aland derer V is extremely natural and
it comes from another nice formula due
to vile which uh Records the volume of a
tubular neighborhood of a manifold
that's isometrically embedded in ukian
space and this can be extended to a
polyhedrin and that's what What U Alan
derve did
okay so in the remaining six minutes let
me describe the motivation for computing
this volume
formula so in fact
proved a um a GP theum for orbifolds and
if one were only interested in Computing
the volumes of complex hyperbolic
orbifolds such as these beautiful 94
examples discovered by delene and mow
one could do it by Computing the oiler
characteristic uh and and then applying
sataki theorem but there's a reason why
I really wanted to be able to do cone
manifolds as well and uh the reason is
there's the following
remarkable uh type of example so take
the group generate of isometries of the
hyperbolic plane generated by
Reflections in the sides of an ideal
pentagon a regular pentagon okay so this
the vertices of this Pentagon are at the
fifth roots of unity now there's a
there's a gwa automorphism of Q adjoined
fifth root of unity that sends the fifth
root of unity to its Square
and if you were to redraw this figure
after applying that automorphism then
one would be connected to Zeta squ then
Zeta 4th then Zeta and then Zeta cubed
and so this figure would go over to um a
regular star and then you could take the
group generated by Reflections in the
sides of this regular star and that
would give a reflection Group which is
almost as good as this one the
difference is this one is badly in IND
discreet so we have a discreet group
here and we have an indiscret cousin
here that's obtained from it by gawa
conjugation but there's a more to the
picture there's a beautiful holomorphic
map which
conjugates the discrete action on one
side to the indiscrete action on the
other side and this map is simply by
obtained by using a mild generalization
of the remon mapping theorem that that
gives you a conformal map from this
pentagon to this star the map has a
critical point at the origin it's
branched over the origin here once you
have that map you can just develop it by
shorts reflection to get a map defined
on the whole dis here and whose image
commutes with this Indiscreet the action
of of this intertwines gamma with this
indiscret group gamma Prime on the other
side okay now here's the question I
would like to ask in this setting this
map is certainly a contraction for the
hyperbolic metric as is any map by the
Schwarz Lemma here's a finite fund
finite sided fundamental domain I can
ask what's the average contraction of
this mapping let's say the contraction
of volume so what is the average value
of frime squar in the hyperbolic
metric well the answer is easy you see
this map this this group here defines a
hyperbolic
orbifold with uh which is an example of
a cone manifold but the but because I
have integers here it's a a special type
that corresponds to a discrete group
there's a corresponding cone manifold on
this side whose holom gives this
indiscrete group gamma Prime and the the
fact that it's the this this gwa
conjugation can be seen here in the fact
that five was replaced by five halves so
this at this vertex we have a cone
manifold that's not locally modeled by
the quotient of hyperbolic plane by a
finite group but it's a cone manifold in
the sense of thiren and what is our map
our map is just the identity map from
this triple punctured sphere to this
triple punctured sphere and so what's
the what is the uh average value of of
the derivative squared it's the ratio of
the volume of this orbifold to the
volume of this cone manifold
and that's in turn the ratio of their
Oiler characteristics so the oiler
characteristic of the triple punctured
sphere is minus one then you put in a
half of a point and a fifth of a point
to make up for these things you get
minus 3/10 here the older characteristic
of minus one you put in a half plus 2 F
and you get minus 1/10th so this guy is
three times bigger than this guy and so
the average value of the derivative is a
third capes and Muller's observation is
that this number a third is an invariant
of the commensurability class of the
group gamma and so
that observation can be
applied uh for example to our our
7778 uh moduli space so um what would
happen if we were to change our choice
of the 18th root of unity this is a
primitive 18th root of unity suppose we
were to change this from Zeta Theus 7 to
Zeta the
minus5 that would correspond to the
modui space for a new set of weights on
these points and the signature of that
the corresponding uh moduli space would
still be one two because of this
pneumonic I just discussed there's still
one point above and two points below so
this object gives rise to a complex
hyperbolic space as does this
moreover there's a map between them
sorry let me bring them both into play
so on this side we have a complex
hyperbolic orbifold on this side we only
have a complex hyperbolic manifold but
they're both obtained by compactifying
the moduli space of Five Points on the
sphere and so because of that it turns
out there's a holomorphic map from this
orbifold to this cone manifold and an
invariant of that map is its volume
contraction which is uh which is again
um simply a ratio of of Oiler
characteristics now why where does these
examples come from and why are they
interesting they they're interesting
because of the fact that when you have a
two different gwa conjugate models for
the same group both of which lie in
non-compact models of the Le group that
means the lattice is a non-arithmetic
lattice if all the gwa conjugate factors
were compact we would have the standard
construction of an arithmetic group but
if there's the corresponding different
real different um uh forms of the group
are have at least two compact factors
then this lattice uh can't possibly be
arithmetic and so this was one of the uh
motivations for delen and Mel's work
using this this construction of complex
hyperbolic metrics on moduli Spaces they
found examples that were
orbifolds but which were not arithmetic
and coming back to mosio rigidity one of
the main remaining open questions is to
what extent is do we have the rigidity
super rigidity of marulas in the setting
of complex hyperbolic geometry and uh
the existence of these non-arithmetic
lates violates the arithmeticity that
one sees in higher rank due to
margulis um okay so let me just complete
this example and finish with an open
question so uh what cies and Mueller
slightly Modified by
my idea of using volume observed is that
these volume R ratios are the same for
all the subgroups of finite index and
Gamma in other words they
commensurability in variance of these
groups and there are 16 non-arithmetic
latices arising from these moduli spaces
using this invariance you can see they
fall into nine commensurability classes
so these are the angles you put on the
uh vertices of the
fiber uh six times punctured sphere
there's the example we've been
discussing the volume ratio turns out to
be a 16th it's the same in variant as
for these weights and these groups turn
out to be uh commensurable of course
non-arithmetic groups commensurable
cousins are also non-arithmetic so you
don't want to cons find the cousins of
the same group that's not a new example
you want to know how many of these
examples are really different from one
another and these invariants cleanly
distinguish all of the known uh
non-arithmetic
examples okay so um that was my
motivation that's the application but of
course this is only the tip of the
iceberg that simply draws attention to
how little we know in this setting so
let me just conclude with the following
two challenges the first challenge is to
find even one nonarithmetic example in
the setting of four complex dimensions
and the second is to determine whether
or not there's only five ly many
non-arithmetic luses up to
commensurability in the two and
threedimensional cases where they've uh
they've been
constructed um okay so I'll stop
[Applause]
there
questions some are yeah it's still
interest that some are and some aren't
that both are
possible
gen so the problem is uh so yes and no
the problem is constructing a canonical
covering so on uh I I already broke a
little bit of Symmetry by putting one
point at Infinity so the point is you
have to have a map from the fundamental
group of your remon surface minus these
end end points to say Zod 18 right so in
for the sphere there's only one map
which sends a peripheral loop around
each puncture to the generator that's
the that's why we have hyperelliptic
curves canonically attached to to end
tuples of points even numbers of points
on a remon Surface there's more choices
for that map but it just has to do with
homology with coefficients in Zod n so
one can make a similar
construction do you
know so these groups are all quotients
of the braid group and the braid group's
homology has been you know very much uh
invest at What's Happening Here is that
when you introduce a cone Locus where
some points collide together they're
you're adding there's a a Dane twist in
the bra group or more properly in the
mapping class group around a loop that
encloses those points and you're when
you add a cone Locus or an orbifold
Locus you're introducing the relation
that an nth power of of that Loop U
becomes the identity and as far as I
know the chology of those quotients has
not been
Computing not even
superu not even by super
[Laughter]
mathematicians as far as I
know well
so okay so oh yeah sure so the no the
minimal examples are arithmetic um yeah
they're very beautiful and for example
that that um there's a whole development
in that area that uh Ruth kellerhouse
and her school have pursued um but from
my perspective it what what's truly
challenging is is Con finding new
constructions of these lates and you
have the sense that the only limitation
is our mathematical
imagination that is if you could just
think of a way of doing this by the way
thon's version of this would be the
following the when you when you have say
an octagon in the plane not a regular
one with with all angles
135° the shapes of these octagons gives
you a complex hyperbolic
manifold and I I remember walking out of
class one day saying I'm mystified by
what you're doing and he said well look
this octagon sits in a square right
so the it's like the sides of the
squares are
ab and uh but then you have to get rid
of these Corners which have sides a b c
and d so the area is a minus a^ 2 - b^ 2
- c^ 2 - D squ and that's a that's a a
form of of signature one uh how many
variables do I have six five and that's
the proof that this has a complex
hyperbolic structure is that the area of
a polygon with its corners off gives
this quadratic form so the quadratic
form at the end of the day is the area
of the
polygon and so you know who knows
whether or not there's a similar
Elementary construction just waiting to
be
discovered